gather round the Maypole friends re
asters midsummer is nearly upon us but
before you head out to the festivities
you may want to know a bit about what
you're getting yourself into
the name re aster may not ring many
bells for you after all midsummer is
only the second movie he's directed but
his debut was one of 2018 s best horror
films hereditary starring Tony Collatz
Gabriel Byrne and Alex wolf is a family
faced with a sudden horrible tragedy
it's a slow burn of a film that ratchets
up the tension all the way through
before unleashing hell in its last act
hereditary was such a total package that
there was even some Best Actress Oscar
buzz for Colette she didn't receive a
nomination but the fact that she was
even in consideration should tell you
something about the kind of poop that
the movie is packin don't let asked her
small filmography fool you
if midsummer can shake audiences like
hereditary did he'll seal his reputation
as a filmmaker who's impossible to
ignore Midsummer's trailer makes it
clear that this is not a movie for the
faint of heart
it looks intense frightening and
unsettling but the director has a few
other ways to describe it that may
surprise you in a discussion with
vulture Astor described midsummer as
quote a breakup movie in the same way
that hereditary was a family tragedy
it's an operatic breakup movie and and a
dark contemporary fairy tale he also
expressed his desire for the movie to be
viewed on its own merits those who go in
expecting the same thing as hereditary
are going to be disappointed as if to
make that distinction clearer he went on
to describe the movie s quote The Wizard
of Oz for perverts that kind of
description alone should be a pretty
good indicator of whether or not
midsummer is the kind of movie you
should see most of Midsummer's cast is
made up of talented young actors who you
may not recognize by name florence Pugh
and Jack Rayner take the lead roles as
Danny and Christian pew is probably most
recognizable for her role as Katherine
in the 2016 film Lady Macbeth but she
also appears in films like outlaw king
fighting with my family and Marvel's
upcoming Black Widow
you might recognize Rainer's voice from
the Andy Serkis directed Mowgli legend
of the jungle where he played brother
wolf he also appeared in the film
grassland alongside Tony Collette and
another of midsummer stars will Poulter
Poulter plays the character mark and you
probably recognize him as Colin from the
interactive Netflix feature black mirror
Bandersnatch though he also played a
prominent role in The Maze Runner series
finally William Jackson Harper plays
Josh he's best known as conflicted
ethics professor Chiddy Anna Gonia on
the good place well I have to see if his
inability to solve the trolley problem
comes up in midsummer why don't you just
tell me the right answer well that's
what's so great about the trolley
problem is that there is no right answer
ah audiences are used to scary films
being set in the dark tricking them with
shadows and obscuring the horrors
lurking just outside their field of
vision it takes just a quick glance at
the marketing / midsummer to realize
that this film operates a little bit
differently everything is very bright
too bright almost the mood seems scary
but the look is all Sun lights and
pastels it makes for an eerie sense of
dissonance even a minor detail like the
letterbox of the trailer being white
instead of the usual black is
off-putting and unnerving that lighting
scheme plays into the themes and plot of
the actual movie which takes place in an
environment of eternal sunlight what
time is it 9:00 p.m. the bright imagery
seems like it will lend itself well to
an otherworldly feel especially as the
plot turns increasingly sinister it will
also make it increasingly difficult for
the protagonists to find a place to hide
so what's really going on in midsummer
according to the official synopsis it
follows Danny and Christian a young
American couple on the verge of breaking
up following a tragedy and Danny's
family she ends up on a trip with
Christian and his friends to a momentous
Midsummer Festival in an isolated
village in Sweden going on a vacation to
fix a broken relationship is in real
life a terrible idea but in the context
of the movie it adds a great deal to the
sense of conflict and emotional tension
between the characters this is probably
why Ari Astor describes midsummer as a
breakup movie it's just going to be an
even more unpleasant breakup than we may
have ever seen before
much of Midsummer's aesthetic comes from
traditional Scandinavian holiday rituals
these midsummer celebrations take place
on a Friday in June in commemoration of
the longest day of the year the
traditions date back to pagan rituals
designed to win the favor of the sun-god
the Midsummer Festival is a big deal in
Sweden typical decorations involve
plenty of flower garlands and wreaths
and businesses shut down so that people
can have the entire day to celebrate
right now summer in Sweden are you gonna
go back and celebrate me out probably
our biggest holiday yeah it's bigger
than New Year's that was a cold
midsummer maypoles for dancing and
gigantic bonfires are common and as the
festivities wind down there is often a
reading of fortune so people can
determine who they will marry in the
future obviously the celebration and
film isn't exactly like these
traditional rites but those traditions
do serve is a clear inspiration for the
more horrifying rituals the movie has in
store if midsummer proves successful you
might see re Esther's name thrown around
as a new master of horror but if you're
expecting him to follow this film up
with another horror feature
you probably shouldn't hold your breath
when indieWIRE spoke with astor about
the film the director made his
intentions for future projects clear
saying midsummer is the only other
horror movie I have and I'm pretty sure
that's going to be it for a long time
I love the genre I consider myself a
genre filmmaker in that I want to play
in every genre I would love to make a
musical he also shared that he's in the
process of writing a sci-fi film and has
four or five movies from his backlog of
scripts quote ready to go he isn't
saying that he'll never return to horror
but it does seem like if he has any say
in the matter it won't happen again for
a while horror movies usually have
fairly brief run times after all it can
be a challenge to keep upping the stakes
of a story without exhausting the
audience to the point of checking out
midsummer is an exception you probably
want to hit the bathroom before settling
in to watch it since the movie sports a
runtime of 2 hours and 20 minutes
and even hereditary couldn't quite slow
burn its way to that wing that movie is
13 minutes shorter than Midsummer's
final cut so don't go into this movie
expecting something simple or easy to
digest like many of the great horror
movies it's not something to just sit
back and watch it's an experience to
endure if you like your horror movies
with loud noises and obvious jump scares
you may want to steer clear from
midsummer a film of the director who
hesitates to even refer to it as a
horror movie in a conversation with
Fandango Astor danced around questions
about just how scary midsummer is saying
it's really leaning more on suspense
than it is scares in some ways it's more
surreal this is an adult contemporary
fairy tale it's worth keeping in mind
that fairy tales can be pretty
horrifying in their own right if you
don't believe us go check out Grimm's
fairy tales or for a more modern take
many of the films of Guillermo del Toro
and remember just because midsummer
doesn't look like a horror film doesn't
mean it won't scare the living daylights
out of you check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]